Vraylar helps smooth the
ups and downs.
♪
>> FREEDOM COMES WITH
RESPONSIBILITY.
YOUR DECISION TO BE UNBE
VACCINATED IMPACTS SOMEONE ELSE.
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE SPREAD THE
VIRUS.
RACHEL: PRESIDENT BIDEN INVOKING
FREEDOM AS HE PUSHES VACCINE
INITIATIVES AND EVEN OFFERING
AMERICANS UP TO $100 TO GET THE
SHOT.
BRIAN: SO WEIRD.
THIS AS MASK MANDATES RETURN FOR
MANY IN THIS COUNTRY INCLUDING
FOR THE FULLY VACCINATED.
FIGURE THAT OUT.
STEVE: HERE WITH REACTION THE
HOST OF THE BEN SHAPIRO SHOW AND
AUTHOR OF THE BRAND NEW BOOK
"THE AUTHORITARIAN MOMENT" BEN
SHAPIRO JOINS US.
HEY, BEN, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> HEY, GOOD MORNING.
STEVE: YOU KNOW, THE WHITE HOUSE
HAS A MESSAGING PROBLEM.
THERE ARE 90 MILLION
UNVACCINATED AMERICANS.
YESTERDAY, THE PRESIDENT MADE
THE CASE EVERYBODY WHO CAN NEEDS
TO GET VACCINATED AND UNTIL
THEN, PEOPLE NEED TO WEAR A
MASK, EVEN THOUGH THEY HAVE HAD
VACCINATIONS, EVEN THOUGH HE
SAID GET THE SHOT AND THEN YOU
DON’T HAVE TO WEAR IT SO THEY
HAVE GOT A MESSAGING PROBLEM,
WHICH THEY INVENTED THEMSELVES.
>> THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS HERE
HAVE COMPLETELY FAILED WHETHER
IT COMES TO MESSAGING THIS
THING.
HERE IS THE REALITY.
OF IF YOU HAVE HAD THE VACCINE
YOU ARE EXTREMELY SAFE FROM CODE
AT THIS POINT.
161 MILLION PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES WHO HAVE BEEN DOUBLE
VAXXED AT THIS POINT.
THERE ARE 6,000 PEOPLE WHO HAVE
HAD BREAK THROUGH INFECTIONS
RESULTING IN HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND ABOUT 1700 PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DIED AFTER THAT.
WHICH MEANS THAT YOUR CHANCES OF
EVEN BEING HOSPITALIZED WITH
CODE AFTER GETTING THE VACCINE
ARE SOMEWHERE AROUND 1 IN 27,000
IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND NOW THEY ARE SAYING THAT THE
VACCINATED ARE SUPPOSED TO MASK
UP TO PREVENT THE UNVACCINATED
FROM GETTING THE DISEASE.
WELL, THERE IS ONLY ONE PROBLEM
WITH THAT THAT ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGES THE UNVACCINATED TO
REMAIN UNVACCINATED BECAUSE
EVERYBODY ELSE IS WORKING TO
PREVENT THEM FROM GETTING THE
INFECTION.
LOOK, THERE ARE ONLY TWO PATHS
HERE.
ONE IS YOU GET VACCINATED AND
IMMUNE OR GET COVID IMMUNE THAT
WAY.
HERB GETS TO CHOOSE.
THAT’S CALLED BEING AN ADULT.
BRIAN: THAT’S KEY.
74% OF THE PEOPLE THAT DO HAVE
BREAKTHROUGHS ARE OVER 65.
SO THAT FURTHER LESSENS THE
CHANCES DEPENDING ON YOUR AGE
BRACKET IN LIFE AND MOST SENIORS
HAVE GOTTEN VACCINATED ALREADY.
YESTERDAY’S STAGE SHOW WAS
REALLY ANXIETY RIDDEN BECAUSE
NOW WE ARE REEMPOWERRING THE
MAYORS AND GOVERNORS WHO
TORTURED US LAST YEAR,
ESPECIALLY OF THE STATE YOU JUST
LEFT IN CALIFORNIA.
>> IT’S MADNESS.
I MEAN, WASHINGTON, D.C. USED TO
ANNOUNCE THESE NEW MASK MAN
DAYS.
WASHINGTON, D.C. HAS A RUNNING
AVERAGE OF ZERO.
ZERO COVID DEATHS EVERY DAY.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY, WHICH IS A
COUNTY OF LIKE 10 MILLION
PEOPLE, LOS ANGELES COUNTY HAS
SINGLE DIGIT COVID DEATHS EVERY
DAY.
LOOKING AT THE CASE RATE DOESN’T
MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
LOOKING AT THE DEATH RATE MAKES
A DIFFERENCE.
THIS IS THE REASON PEOPLE ARE
SUPPOSED TO GET VACCINATED
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOW DISCONNECTED
THE CASE RATE FROM THE DEATH
RATE.
IF WE ARE ONLY GOING TO FOCUS IN
ON THE CASE RATE AND NOT ON THE
DEATH RATE WHO IS GOING TO GET
VACCINATED?
RACHEL: SUCH A GREAT POINT, BEN.
I WANT TO GET YOUR BOOK BECAUSE
I THINK WE ARE IN AN
AUTHORITARIAN MOMENT.
I THINK IT’S A GRIT TITLE.
HERE IS AN EXCERPT FROM IT A
SMALL NUMBER OF LEFTIST COLLEGE
COASTAL AND UNCOMPROMISING HAVE
NOT JUST TAKEN OVER THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY OUR CORPORATIONS OUR
UNIVERSITIES, OUR SCIENTIFIC
ESTABLISHMENT OUR CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS AND USED THEIR NEW
FOUND POWER TO SILENCE THEIR
OPPOSITION.
BEN, CONSERVATIVES LIKE YOU HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE TAKEOVER
BY THE LEFT OF THE CULTURE OF
HOLLYWOOD, OF EDUCATION, I HAVE
BEEN REALLY SURPRISED AT HOW
THOROUGHLY THEY HAVE INFILTRATED
GOVERNMENT, GOVERNMENT.
THE NATIONAL SECURITY, NOW THE
MILITARY TALK TO ME ABOUT THIS
AUTHORITARIAN MOVEMENT BUT ALSO
WHAT’S THE SOLUTION TO THIS?
THE WAY THE INSTITUTIONS WERE
TAKEN OVER VERY HARD CORE OF 20%
OF A GROUP, 20% OF ANY GROUP
INSIDE A INSTITUTION
UNCOMPROMISING AND INSISTS ON
GETTING ITS WAY BURK IN THE
MIDDLE APATHETIC OR SHY.
THAT’S WHAT’S HAPPENED IN ALL OF
THESE INSTITUTIONS.
THE GOOD NEWS IS YOU CAN DO IT
IN REVERSE IF 20% OF THE
CORPORATION, 20% OF EMPLOYEES
GET TOGETHER AND SAY WE ARE NOT
DOING X IN OPPOSITION TO THE
LEFT THEN THEY CAN SWING THAT
BACK THE OTHER WAY AND
NEUTRALITY INSTITUTIONS THAT
REQUIRES IT POLITICAL
UNIONIZATION MOVEMENT BY
CONSERVATIVES OR MODERATES IN A
VARIETY OF AREAS IN AMERICAN
LIFE.
IF THAT DOESN’T HAPPEN, THE LEFT
IS GOING TO CONTINUE ITS MARCH
THROUGH THE INSTITUTION.
STEVE: CHECK OUT THE BOOK.
IT’S NOW AVAILABLE EVERYWHERE.
I’M SURE IT’S GOING TO BE A BIG
NUMBER ONE BEST SELLER CALLED